it's become a trademark of the
opposition movement
a symbol of resistance the
three-fingered salute
borrowed from science fiction
blockbuster the hunger games
thousands of protesters gathered at
tamasak university on the outskirts of
bangkok
to listen to pro-democracy activists and
to lend their voice to a movement
that is gathering momentum in thailand
[Applause]
i'm not happy and i support our demands
dissolve parliament
get the government to resign fix the
constitution and stop
threatening people the prime minister is
abusing his power
he doesn't care about people's rights
i decided to join the protest because
the government is eroding our rights
mainly i want a constitution with
integrity
and i want those who are taking away
people's rights to be out of power
people's anger here is mainly directed
at prime minister prayu chanocha and his
government
prayut is a former army chief who led a
coup in 2014.
last year he was elected as prime
minister in an election
critics saw as rigged in favour of his
party and the army
but activists have also started
addressing an even more
sensitive issue the role of the monarchy
in thailand
protesters have issued a 10-point call
for reform of the monarchy
including an overhaul of a draconian
royal defamation law
which protects the powerful king
mahavajira longhorn
it's one of the strictest less majestic
laws in the world
anyone who insults the monarchy can be
punished by up to 15 years in prison
two activists were arrested at a
demonstration on friday but later
released
were on stage challenging the taboo
[Applause]
we shouldn't have to speak using symbols
direct discussion is best
that's what i think so i choose to speak
directly
out of respect for my own dignity for
that of the listeners
and for the monarchy as an institution
i just want to say that to speak out
about the institution of the monarchy
is something we can do
the prime minister has warned protesters
not to involve the monarchy in their
alleys
though he said the king had asked him
not to arrest anyone under the
defamation law
organisers say their next rally will be
held on wednesday
a national holiday commemorating the
queen
mother's birthday janjira sumatun siri
is a political scientist
and associate fellow at the german
institute for global and
area studies welcome jajira what has
prompted
these latest protests
um well in one word it would be
democratic deficits in thailand despite
the election
and um there are other issues connected
to this
um the the institutional
drafting in 2016 that
is seen as undemocratic
and continuing human rights violation by
the government so
um i think all of this has
led to the students demand for greater
democracy
and um at the bottom of this um
i would see that they we are witnessing
the
continuation of the clashes between two
political missions in thailand
one is rather conservative the other is
rather progressive
as you mentioned this is a continuation
of
previous clashes that have been
happening in a thai polity
what is different this time round
well the the main difference is that the
the forefront
um activists players in this conflict is
um the younger people the younger
generation basically university students
high school students who
are hopeless about their future in the
country to be honest
um they are linking democratic deficits
in the country
with economic inequality and with the
fact that they have no future whatsoever
in the country and um i think they are
actually digging in the root cause of
why
um they are having no filter in the
country and i think you know
um we find that root cause in the
what political scientists would define
as
um autocratic persistence in the midst
of
uh these calls for change protesters are
also calling for a
reform of the monarchy how significant
is that
it's very significant um i would say
that this is a new
chapter in thailand's political history
for the first time
um protesters um speak
about the unspeakable topic in public
and they speak they speak about this uh
with with dignity and with politeness
um they what all they want is a
democratic reform
of the most sacred institution of the
country
and i think maybe it's time thai people
start to think about that protesters
were also calling for the resignation of
the prime minister prayuth
chan ocha who of course came to power in
elections uh
last year but there have also been
protests in support
of the government is the praiuchan ocha
government
actually popular in thailand
i would say he remains for youth uh
osha as a person remains popular
amongst his conservative constituents
but the party that um he
although he's not a part of the ruling
party but he's associated
with that ruling party and the party
shows every side
of corruption of infighting of
every all aspects of politics in
in thailand so i think right now we are
seeing that
we are seeing the crisis of faith
in the um and osha regime
if you like but not as a person so yes
protesters are demanding his resignation
as a representative of this regime
how do you see these uh student protests
planning out janjira do you
expect any political change to happen
um i think we we are going to see
a long stalemate um
as a thai person um i don't think that
these protests
could um bring about the changes that
um protesters some of the protests some
of the protesters are really demanding
for example the fanatical reform but
i think is a stepping stone for
um the next chapter of our history
chandira sumbat punsari we'll have to
leave it there for the time being but
thank you so much for joining us